et avant de découvrir un canton lilian
une mise au point
oui hier soir nous vous annoncions la
suspension des candidats ump dissident
de la chapelle de guinchay de mâcon 1
dont l'ancien député gérard voisin on
sait qu'une véritable guerre oppose
depuis des années au maire de mâcon
jean-patrick courtois et gérard voisin
n'a pas apprécié du tout nous donnions
cette information est sur son blog ce
matin ils nous accusent de ne pas avoir
vérifié nos sources il parle d'erreur
déontologiques et évoque une demande de
réparation
donc nous le remercions pour cette leçon
de déontologie mais nous lui conseillons
d'aller à la poste chercher ce courrier
recommandé avec accusé de réception
partie de l'ump rue de vaugirard vous
voyez les images le 4 mars et signée du
secrétaire général laurent wauquiez dans
ce courrier laurent wauquiez écrit vous
entretenez la confusion et la désunion
auprès de nos adhérents et plus loin le
bureau politique a décidé à l'unanimité
de vous suspendre de notre mouvement
ce qui va poser souci d'ailleurs puisque
le nom ump figurent sur les documents de
campagne de gérard voisin
on le voit nous avions donc vérifier nos
sources voilà c'est dit on passe comme
tous les soirs un canton les miens oui
celui de dijon troyes il regroupe
plusieurs quartiers dans le cadre du
nouveau redécoupage avec la toison d'or
et les grésille des quartiers aux
problématiques très différentes
droite et gauche ont misé chacun sur la
proximité pour remporter la bataille
mais le fn là aussi va peser un
reportage de liseron g et christophe
gaillard aux grésillés hamid el hassouni
est chez lui il a grandi dans ce
quartier populaire où il vit toujours
l'adjoint au maire de dijon et son
binôme écologistes ont le projet
d'appliquer au département ce qui peut
être fait à la ville une campagne de
terrain au plus près des électeurs car
la gauche craint la montée du front
national doublé d'un vote sanction
la démobilisation de l'électorat de
gauche pourrait permettre c'est une
hypothèse à prendre avec des pincettes
pourrait permettre donc de voir le front
national au second tour
évidemment je nous allons nous mobiliser
pour éviter ce scénario catastrophe est
véritablement je crois qu'il existera un
élan citoyen parce que je sais que dans
les quartiers populaires contrairement
aux idées reçues il y à une forte
hostilité vis-à-vis du front national
notamment l'émergence d'une vague bleu
marine au fn on y croit quand
socioprofessionnelles c'est assez bien
représenter le canton trop aux grésillés
l'an dernier le parti d'extrême droite
était arrivée en tête des élections
européennes
principal argument pour ce nouveau
scrutin la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
le fn compte bien poursuivre sa
stratégie d'implantation locale
élections le front national développe
vraiment les sujets qui intéressent les
français c'est ça tout ce qui est de
leur vie quotidienne on est vraiment
proche d'eux et et je pense que le côté
pervers de l'austérité on est seul parti
qui vraiment le défendre alors si on
faisait une augmentation de 10 points
oui je pense qu'on peut être au deuxième
tour et moi je pense qu'ils vont voter
pour nous
majoritairement je pense je pense qu'on
aura des surprises des surprises qui ont
aussi de quoi inquiéter l'ump en
campagne dans le quartier de la toison
d'or donc c'est la carte qu'on laisse
aux habitants lorsqu'on veut en porte à
porte sur l'action sociale laurent
bourguignat et son tandem udi met la
priorité sur la reconnaissance du mérite
et la lutte contre l'assistanat un
discours de droite dure qui rappelle les
thèmes du fn
nous devons tout mettre en oeuvre pour
garantir aux contribuables que lors que
leurs impôts sont bien gérées et qu'il
aille
s'agissant du système de protection
sociale à ceux qui en ont vraiment
besoin qu'ils ont envie de s'en sortir
ils sont majoritaires mais cette
majorité est minée par par tous ceux qui
abusent du système et ceux qui abusent
du système il faut les traquer et les
sanctionner sans relâche sévèrement
fermement dans ce canton près de 12000
300 électeurs sont invités à se
prononcer les 22 et 29 mars prochains
et sur ce canton de dijon 3 sont aussi
candidats christine truchot des sols et
didier porto pour le front de gauche et
la côte d'or ce sera le thème de notre
émission politique et louis troisième
débat de notre série à 11 heures jusqu'à
12h20 demain partenariat avec le bien
public sur le plateau de la voie est
libre colette popard pour le ps c'est
dwarka main pour le front national
isabelle de almeida pour le front de
gauche dominique grimperait pour le
modem et emmanuel bichot pour l'ump
puisque le président françois sauvadet
n'a pas souhaité modifier son agenda
pour participer à ce débat et de chez
vous vous pouvez intervenir sur notre
site internet et sur twitter avec le
hashtag f3 bourgogne et lvl bourgogne à
demain 11 heures s'est dotée merci lire
un dossier complet également sur notre
site internet